Panel session to be
moderated by Limor Peer.
Limor Peer is the
Associate Director
for Research at the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies
at Yale University.
She oversees research
infrastructure and process
at ISPA, including the Field
Experiment Initiative, which
encourages field
experimentation in
interdisciplinary collaboration
in the social sciences.
In this capacity,
she's led the creation
of a specialized research
data repository, the ISPA data
archive.
Limor also serves as a
research data policy specialist
in the Office of
the Provost and is
working on campus wide efforts
relating to research data.
And she has the
coolest first name.
So I'd like to keep this
as informal as possible.
This is the end of the day, and
I think we've all heard a lot
and have a lot to digest
and a lot to process.
And by the way,
speaking of digestion,
if anyone wants to grab a
cup of coffee, that's fine.
So I'm thinking of this
as just a conversation.
I mean, from my point
of view, I would just
like to sit back and let these
guys talk among themselves
and just listen to that.
So I think that's where
we're going to try to go.
But I did want to say just maybe
a few things in the beginning.
First, just to thank you all
for agreeing to do this today.
I think that we're
very fortunate to have
this stellar panel of--
couldn't ask for a better set
of keynote speakers and folks
that can really make the
case for open science
that I think a lot of people
in this room are supporting,
and that we are all
sharing the mission that we
need to spread the word
and get it out and make
real change fast.
All of these speakers
also lead by example.
And they've made open science
and research transparency
a priority alongside
their academic careers,
which I find quite amazing.
And I think they should
be saluted for that.
So we've heard about
the work of the Center
for Open Science, the
Open Science Framework,
the Reproducibility Project.
We've heard from Erin
about her advocacy
work, her personal
pledge, and the work
she does to educate researchers.
And we've heard from Harlan.
Harlan's a leader in open
data on clinical trials
and the [INAUDIBLE] project
and some other things related
to that.
We heard a lot about
the benefits of openness
to science as a whole.
I really liked
Brian's, I think it
was yesterday's talk
at the Psychology
Department about your
motivation for starting
this whole thing was realizing
that there's a gap between how
we idealize science and how
we actually practice it,
and being a psychologist,
kind of realizing some
of the reasons for that gap
having to do with things
like biases and human
nature, but then coming up
with a way to kind of try
to tackle that and reduce
that gap.
So benefits for science,
doing science better.
Benefits for
scientists, so things
that will improve their career
and make it better for them
and better for
society and better
for research subjects,
which I think
didn't quite come
up as much, but I
know that it's one of the
things that Harlan really
works on as well.
So I guess I want to just
throw out a question to you
to bring it back to some of the
remarks that Steve Girvin made.
Seems like a long time ago.
It was this morning.
So because open science,
really, it's an ecosystem.
And we have a lot of players.
We have researchers.
We have academic societies.
We have institutions.
We have funders.
We have industry.
We have journals,
we have libraries,
and we have technology and
other support services.
I want to ask you to zoom in on
the institutions for a minute,
because if we're talking about
fast progress in this area,
maybe some of these stakeholders
have gone faster than others
if we charted them out.
What are your thoughts
about where institutions
are in this sort of
progress, and especially
in light of some concerns
that I have coming from--
in the US, it's different,
for example, in the UK,
where some of the
national policies
inform the research councils,
and then the research councils
tell the universities what to
do, when they have to do it.
We don't really have that.
And the recent
statements from the--
what is it, the Association
for American Universities,
might lead one to believe
that there is maybe a little
some resistance in how the
universities see themselves
complying with some of
the federal mandates
for opening up data.
So that's my question.
I'll let you go with that.
You want me to jump in here?
Yeah, so I think--
I mean, it depends a lot what
institution you're looking at.
So some institutions
have been great in kind
of pushing things forward.
But I think what I would love
to see more from institutions
is a better match between
what they say they value
and what they're
actually rewarding.
So a lot of institutions have
these very explicit mission
statements that say, we
value communicating science.
We value reaching
out to the public.
We are a public
institution that should
be interacting with citizens.
But at the time where we're
evaluating researchers
for hiring or
promotion and tenure,
we're not giving them credit
for communicating their results
to the public or
sharing their results.
We're giving them more
points for locking it up
in a journal like
Nature and Science
than we are for dissemination.
And so I would love to see more
initiatives from institutions
to have a better mismatch,
to reform their evaluations
and start valuing some
of these things more,
and really kind of meet
their mission statements,
because I think that this
is something that we can all
agree, reaching out to the
public should be a good thing
and should be something that an
academic institution is doing.
But if we're just locking up
these results in journals,
and we're furthermore
writing it in language
that the public
can't understand,
that's not reaching out
to the public in any way.
So I think a lot of institutions
have been very cautious,
and every department says
no, we're a unique snowflake
and we can't possibly have
kind of general recommendations
about how we could
reform evaluation.
But I think we have to think
a lot more about those things.
Yeah, I totally agree with
the aligning incentives
with what the goals are for
the institutional mission
and scholarship,
as Erin describes.
Another element of where
I think institutions still
have work to do on the
infrastructure side
is in finding ways
to actually integrate
the tools and services for
doing science more openly
with the researchers' workflow.
So just as an
example, I have never
once used the
institutional repository
at University of Virginia.
I'm probably among the
more committed people
to open science at the
University of Virginia,
and I've never used it because
it is not at all linked
to the workflows in my lab.
It never comes up
to think, oh, I
should deposit my articles in
our institutional repository.
And I raised this with some
colleagues in the library,
and they said, oh, that's
probably a good idea,
because they said
oh, and no one else
uses our repository either.
And I mentioned that
the way that you
can get me to use
the repository is,
each year I have to submit
an annual report of all
the research that I did.
Of course it's in
a Word document.
And I cut and paste from
my vitae what work was,
which is a problem on its own.
But if instead, during
that reporting process,
I just said, add your papers--
it was a little web form and
I'm dropping my papers in,
and that automatically put
them into the institutional
repository-- then
everybody's papers on campus
would be in the
institutional repository.
Why?
Because we fill out that form
because we want our raise.
So it's in our workflow.
We have a reason to do it.
And so you have to
think about what
is it that actually engages
people in the workflow
that they have in
order to get them
to use the services that the
organization's providing,
right?
Just saying do it
isn't sufficient.
Yeah.
So the University of
Liege, I think, in Belgium
is actually doing this.
So it's a requirement
now that if you
want any product, any
research product considered
for promotion and tenure, it
has to be in their open access
institutional repository.
And there was this
great quote, actually,
just a few hours ago on
Twitter from the NIH Director
that said, if you
want to herd cats,
the best way is to
move the food bowl.
And so this idea of being--
incentives are important.
So if you tell them your
raise depends on this,
your promotion and
tenure depends on this,
they're going to do it.
It's not just build
it and they will come.
They won't come unless you
give them a reason to come.
And then there's another add-on
to that, which is recognition
that most researchers are not
concerned with open science.
And that's not
saying researchers
are opposed to open science.
It's that the concern
of the researcher
is the problems that
they're trying to solve,
the questions that they're
investigating in the lab.
So I have a great test case.
For all the things that
we do at the center,
my test case for whether
this is going to work at all
is whether my wife
gets interested in it.
She runs a lab at UVA,
and most of the time
she has no interest at all in
what we're doing because she's
trying to figure
out the cognitive
processes underlying anxiety
disorders and fixing that.
That the papers are available
open access, well, that's fine.
Yeah, I hope other people
will be influenced by it.
But it's not what she
thinks about every day.
And so it's another
one of those occasions
of presuming that
someone-- she's
totally pro-open science
in the principles,
but because she's
not thinking about it
in terms of the practices,
what we have to provide
is easy way to live
by those principles
so that she can stay
focused on the things that
are the problems
she's trying to solve.
And so any institutional
process has
to be attentive
to what's actually
driving the person's
behavior, and how do we just
become part of that?
Don't add onto the workflow.
Integrate with their work flow.
So these are
interesting suggestions.
I guess-- and I'm looking for
you, Brian, as a psychologist,
is to think about
how do you create--
how do you make it
normative in a way that
isn't top down requirement,
but recognizing that your wife
or others will see this as not
just the right thing to do,
but actually making their
lives richer and better?
And you start thinking about
what some of the pain points
are.
I mean, some of the
pain points are,
you spend all this
time doing a paper.
It's a static paper.
And I think a lot of them are
confetti papers, you know?
They get a little attention
for a little bit of time,
and then they sort of fall away.
They don't nearly get the
eyeballs that they could get,
or aren't getting to
the right audiences that
might foster the
kind of commentary
and push you to better
work, and actually
help you see solutions.
And in the beginning,
as investigators,
I think we're taught,
hold everything tight.
I'm the one with the ideas.
And it's only through
collaborative efforts
where you say, I never would
have come up with this idea
if I hadn't had some sort
of resonance with somebody
else who was challenging
me, or that the group hadn't
been able to do that.
And so I guess I have
this wish to think
that we can create the tools
so that it gets out there,
and create fostering communities
and interactions that
never would have existed.
And then in some way
you're able to also--
it's not just about
citations, but it's actually
about energy that's
generated around ideas.
Because otherwise
we're producing papers
and then they get
forgotten really quickly,
in part because they never get
to people who it might spark.
The most excitement I
get is when someone says,
I read one of your papers, and
it led me to do something else.
And I just know
that a lot of people
are shielded with access.
If I think about the world, I
mean, certainly in our country,
if you're associated with a
university you're going to get
access to a lot of this stuff.
But there are a lot of people
around the world who may not
be able to be exposed
to some of these ideas
because of the way and
the costs and so forth.
So we have to think about ways
of making these cases that it
creates a more
vibrant community,
more satisfying career and life.
And that actually is
going to produce, even
for you, better science.
And I know that may
be a pipe dream,
but it's something
about feeding into that,
because I do believe if it feels
like one more darn thing I've
got to--
because it seems like
every year, as faculty,
we're asked to do more
compulsory training
on something.
The list is like this.
You've got to--
you know, I've got
to take all these
online assessments.
And they don't feel energizing,
and I don't necessarily
feel like it's
improving my competence
or making me better at anything.
I'm just someone's check box.
And I think the degree to which
this becomes somebody's check
box because we're telling
them it's making things
better rather than finding
out ways we can authentically
do that-- and that's why I was
asking you when we met before,
how do we know the
science has gotten better?
You We need to be able to say,
this is a tool for the endgame.
The endgame is we're actually
better producing science.
Like if we go through all of
this and on the other side
we're just the same as we
are now, then all we've done
is create a lot of extra work.
And so we've got to figure out
how does it actually enhance
the output, make it either
more efficient or more clever?
And that's I think
our central challenge,
so that we're not just
sitting here telling people
it's the right
thing to do, we're
going to put in
these regulations,
but that we're saying it's
a competitive advantage.
Last thing I'll
say about this is--
because I have this same
conversation in medicine
around decision support tools.
A lot of the docs are saying
it takes too long to engage
in decision support.
I'm smart enough, you know.
I've memorized all this stuff.
And what you want
to say is once they
can start looking
at their outcomes,
it's like the athletes.
You don't see any of
the athletes saying,
somebody's got a new
training regimen that ends up
making them faster,
everyone else wants
to figure out what that is.
I mean, you like
that they stay legal.
But on the Olympic
side, you want
to give yourself every
advantage for performance.
And what I want this is to
be performance-enhancing.
And if this becomes
performance-enhancing,
then things will
fall into place.
Then give credit for that.
I mean, that's part
of it, performance
enhancing in what your job is as
a member of the community, too.
But if it's
performance-enhancing,
I think people will run to it.
If it seems like it's another
weight tied around my legs
that's making it hard for me to
swim, because I just don't have
enough time do my research
any more because I'm spending
40% of my time complying
with all these mandates,
then I don't think it's
a long-term winner.
That's just my general
ideas about it.
Yeah.
These are real good
issues to identify.
And to take one step
back and then go into it,
the presumption of training--
and this is an academic
presumption, by and large--
is that we have to change--
we have to persuade people,
change their attitudes
and beliefs, and their
behavior will follow.
Most of the evidence suggests
it's lot easier do the reverse,
change the behavior, and
their attitudes and beliefs
will follow.
So set the conditions so that
the behaviors happen naturally.
Not that I have to do
all this extra work
or fill out all the
extra forms or think
about this new process.
But give me a tool that makes
it easy for me to do something
that I already want to do.
I'm not persuading
you about anything.
I already want to
collect my data.
All things being
equal, I want to do it.
Right.
And then all of a sudden, it
also adds on this other thing.
Oh, it turns out my research
is more reproducible because I
used this tool that was
an awesome analytics tool,
and all the code spit out, and
then it put it on this website.
And then someone else clicks
go and all of the results
come out again.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, actually, you know what?
I'm glad that's there.
Oh, I believe in
reproducibility.
So the key for these is not,
let's build persuasion campaign
and convince people that despite
the incentives of the system,
despite the inconvenience,
despite all these forms
you have to fill out now,
it's a good thing to do.
Instead, focus on the tools.
How do we insert ourselves
into their workflows
so that they can just do it,
and then persuade themselves?
And the other part of that is
that there isn't persuading
that's needed in the
ultimate endgame,
because you noted that
people are saying,
I need to hold this for myself.
I'm resisting.
But simultaneously, I
want to have influence.
Everybody wants to
have influence, right?
What is an academic's success?
It's reputation.
If an academic went into
science to make money,
they made a bad career choice.
They could make lots of money
in other ways more easily.
The academic's real
thing is reputation.
How do we get reputation?
We have influence, we have
impact, people pay attention
to what we're doing.
Being closed in different
parts of the process
interferes with that.
But the reason that we feel
like we need to be closed
is because the entire
mindset is about,
I need to be close to
get the publication.
The publication is my means
to reputation enhancement.
And so breaking that system
is breaking the publication
as it is the bottleneck.
Everything is about
the publication,
and if you can break
that bottleneck,
then the I get impact, I get
attention, I get interest,
I get people talking to me
about stuff is now open.
The entire process is
an opportunity for me
to have impact, for other people
to pay attention to what I'm
doing, how I designed my study.
Other people start to say, oh,
that's a really interesting
question.
Let me help.
Or oh, that question is now
inspiring me to do this thing.
And it's no longer
interfering with me
to have you start to take my
ideas earlier, because it's not
about the publication anymore.
It's about me
influencing you, wherever
I am in the research cycle.
Where do you see this going?
Say that we're successful to
some extent and at some point,
and we have more and more
demand for open science
from our funders, and maybe
from researchers themselves,
and more supply.
We know that that's coming.
So what unforeseen
problem might be something
that we're not thinking
about right now
that might come up that
has to do with open science
that we-- because it seems that
the way we're thinking about it
is it solves a lot of problems,
and it's a good thing.
But are there some
problems that it
could create that we
should maybe think about?
So yeah.
I think-- I mean, we've
touched on some of the issues,
privacy issues.
There might be times where
disclosing certain information
is not good for the patient.
So I think those are kind
of the more obvious cases.
I think one that I hear a
lot, and I don't necessarily
have a good answer for, is
simply too much information.
So if you're trying to keep
up with a certain field,
there are already
too many articles
being published for me
to keep up with that.
If you're going to add pre-print
literature to that, and data
sets, and protocols, and all
kinds of interim research
products that we think it's a
good thing to release those,
there's a filtering issue.
So I can't handle,
I can't process
all of that information.
How are we going to put some
types of filters in place
that allow us to pick
out the stuff that's
most relevant to us
and go with that?
So I think that's not yet an
issue we've entirely solved.
I don't think that should--
I don't think-- sorry,
yeah, yeah, I know.
So I don't think that should
prevent us from going forward.
But I think it's
something that we're
going to have to think
of going forward.
You know, I mean, I see day
where we're solving problems
together.
Nobel Prizes don't go out
to three or few people,
but they recognize the team
nature of this science,
and that we're each
trying to push forward.
But I do think we come back to
this issue about in the end,
there is some curation
that's going to be needed,
so how does that curation occur?
I was saying to
Brian, in my field
there are very small
but highly vocal
people around particular
issues that represent outliers.
Now not saying their voice
doesn't deserve to be heard,
but for example, people
are anti-vaccine.
And they could threaten
the public's health.
And do they have an opportunity
to express their opinion?
Sure, but if but if you've
got a small number of people
pelting the comments in
disproportionate fashion,
you can have a
misappreciation of what
the community is thinking.
So how you curate this,
what represents a danger
if the information is
getting out in a certain way,
how do you how to
control what really
should be reasonable discourse?
That is, one side does think
the other side is crazy.
The other side thinks
the other side's crazy.
But actually both of them have--
we don't know who's right
yet, versus one where there's
a group that's truly an outlier
opinion that potentially
could threaten the public's
health by saying something that
is--
everyone should be taking
cyanide tablets, I don't know.
You know, something--
this is a cure for cancer,
like they did for
apricot pits for awhile.
But the question is
how to curate that.
And I think the issue
of credit does come down
because we can't ignore this.
So we've got a university.
Someone's is trying
to build a career.
I want to give her
credit for the influence.
I want to give her special
credit if she produces data
that other people are using.
I want to consider that
even better than a citation
because that study never would
have been possible if you
hadn't produced that data.
But the institutions
are slow to move,
and we're slow to understand
how to measure that influence.
So when a junior person is
coming up doing good work,
being extraordinarily generous,
adopting this kind of approach,
I worry.
How are we going to make sure
that we can keep up with that
and not lose that
talent because there
are early adopters of what is
really the right thing to do?
And I think those are issues
that we're going to figure out.
I agree with all those.
They cover a lot of
the broad domain.
I think the key--
for me, the umbrella issue
is that the biggest risk
is being comfortable
with the status quo.
Whatever change we make to
now it's open, now it's this,
we're done.
That is the wrong method.
We have to have, I think, in
order for this to be effective,
an actual discipline
of meta science
emerge that is truly the
interdisciplinary discipline,
which is a constant evaluation
and iteration of refinement
of the process of scholarly
communication and research.
Without that, we
will not identify
unintended consequences,
and we will
fail to improve the ones
where things are actually
not operating as efficiently
or effectively as they could.
Beautifully said.
One challenge that comes to
my mind when I hear that is--
because I've been around
librarians for a long time--
is the preservation
of these materials
and the usage of them
in the long term.
And what are your
thoughts on that?
Who is responsible for that?
Who is responsible
for preserving?
I don't know.
And you know, producing
multiple terabytes
a second is mind blowing for
thinking about preservation
of data.
But there are lots of
interesting solutions
that are emerging and
will continue to emerge.
And so to me, the problem right
now is to get to the point
where we have a problem
with actually preserving
the data we need, because
that would be a great problem
to have.
So one solution that we've been
exploring with some prototypes
is using torrents models
for data preservation.
So torrents are usually
used for teenagers
to share movies when
they're not supposed to.
But they can be used
for good purposes, which
is every machine has
a bit of space that's
dedicated to hosting data.
And so I'd donate a few
gigabytes of my hard drive
and you'd donate a few
gigabytes of yours.
It distributes it, and it is
a great preservation device
because you can get many, many
copies in many different places
and track [INAUDIBLE].
For preserving the
origins of things,
the blockchain has lots
of interesting potentials
for provenance and registration
and things like that.
So there's
technology's constantly
emerging that can help
solve some of the problems.
And then what data
to get rid of.
And then museums have a whole
history of thinking about what
is the decision
process for deciding
what to preserve because
we can't preserve it all?
So I worry less about
that in the sense
that, yeah, when those
are real problems,
we figure out how to
solve those problems.
CERN is a great
example of having
lots of real principled
decisions about when
and how to get rid of data.
I'd just drop it because it's
not what needs to be preserved.
Let's open it up to everyone.
My question is about
pre-prints, because it
sounds like there are more and
more possibilities to submit
a pre-print.
And I think for most of us, the
traditional peer review process
is really painful.
And I always think
the reviewers feel
forced to come up with
really crazy ideas
or be really creative
in suggesting
impossible experiments.
Sometimes it's to really
improve their publications.
Sometimes it's not.
At least that's my opinion.
So back to pre-prints,
is there any evidence
that a submitting a
pre-print would really
accelerate the time of
until the actual publication
of a manuscript?
And the second question
is if there is the fear
that reviewers will
also look at some
of the suggestions published
in these pre-print services
and just come up
with even more ideas
so that you end up
doing more experiments.
At the end the application
will be very long,
will probably have
a lot of authors,
and will be much better
than the first manuscript.
But at the end, it will be
very time-consuming and also
very costly to finish it.
Yeah.
So it's a good question.
I don't know if there's ever
been a controlled study that
looked at whether manuscripts
that had been published
on a pre-print server go
through the peer review process
faster, for example, than
ones that were submitted
to that type of platform.
My anecdotal experience
is just that having
those eyes on the paper and
getting a lot of community
feedback before I
submit to peer review
has helped me clean
up a lot of issues,
tackle kind of the biggest
issues in my papers.
And I felt like the
peer review process
after that, then, has
gone very smoothly.
So again, that that's
not a controlled study.
It's anec-data.
But for me, that's my
personal experience.
So this recent paper that we
wrote together, so we actually
opened that up on Google
Docs and invited people
to come in and give comments.
And that allowed us to kind
of identify and really tackle
major issues, and then the peer
review process at the journal
went fairly quickly.
I don't know if there's
ever been a systematic study
on pre-prints.
I can't think of one.
But that would be
an awesome thing
to do for exactly the
reasons you identify,
because that would
be interesting.
You can come up with plausible
stories in both directions.
The positive story
and accelerating,
but the interference
story, as you describe it.
So that's a study worth doing.
So the only studies I am
aware of on pre-prints
is some of the citation
studies surrounding
pre-prints, so in physics
and mathematics especially,
the articles that were
published on archive
prior to journal
submission and publication.
Obviously they started
to get citations
sooner because they
were available sooner,
but then they maintained
the citation advantage
for months or years afterwards.
So that's an obvious visibility
benefit for researchers.
Whether there are costs
that kind of outweigh that,
I'm not sure.
And I'm not sure those
things have been measured.
I have both a comment
and a question.
Comment is about getting
more and more open data
and open applications
that we can use.
I overlook one big
group of people
next to going into
society, which
are the groups that are not
in an Ivy League university.
I know that I'm very privileged
with my whole education system.
And visiting
universities or colleges
that want to use and want
to partake in hypothesis
and research, and I'm using, for
example, Matlab or Mathematica,
and they don't have that.
That's why I think it's
also a very important thing
to emphasize that we as
researchers, from such
a privileged university, should
also emphasize that we have
our colleagues at other
universities that really
benefit from it.
But we need to be the
drivers, because to be fair,
they do look up to us.
So if we are the first
one to implement that,
they definitely will follow.
That was my comment.
My question is more about we
already were discussing that
and were going into
that direction in a way
that what we see now, and what's
also now in public debated,
is when everything is open
and we get facts and news,
how are we going to deal
with that social way of who
is going to pick what
is right information,
and what is the right
kind of data or research
we're going to follow?
Because we do see that now
in public news sharing,
these kind of things.
But that probably is
also a consequence
of having all this open data and
all this kind of open research
debating, because if we don't
have a curated list there
anymore, then we base them
why certain people get popular
on prejudices of others.
So my question is,
how do you want
to tackle that instead
of curating or maybe
not creating open access?
Both good comments.
I'll address the first, and
you guys can answer the second.
I think something that's
often overlooked--
and we did in our
discussions by and large
here, although not completely.
I think Erin made
some good points--
is that open science isn't
just about transparency.
Openness also means
inclusivity, right along
the point that you made, which
is, it really breaks down
barriers that are because of
unequal resource distribution.
So one of the questions
earlier was about doing studies
in multiple samples.
Samples vary, especially
human samples,
and so we need to look at
variation in those effects.
We have organized
many labs projects
where we take the same protocol
and invite any lab that
wants to run it to run the exact
same protocol to investigate
that very question.
And those kinds of studies have
been very popular among groups
that are in institutions that
don't have dedicated research
resources.
And the faculty
are spending most
of their time teaching
rather than having time
to do research.
And the reason is that they
have passion and interest
and expertise in doing research.
They just don't have
resources or grad students
or other things to do
a generative research
program starting from scratch
and building up the ideas
and blah blah blah.
But to be able to participate,
if another group is saying OK,
we'll organize these materials,
we'll organize the protocols,
and then your role is like this.
But it's a real role,
it is a meaningful role
as dramatically expanded
inclusion in that.
Same thing with open data.
I gave a talk at University of
Belgrade a couple of years ago.
And when I was talking
to the graduate students,
they were all doing research
in my subdomain, implicit bias.
So why are you guys all
studying implicit bias?
And they said, well, all
the people in your subfield
put their papers online
and so we can get them.
So that's why we
study implicit bias.
Like, oh my gosh, OK.
Wow.
That makes me feel like I'm
going to continue doing that.
And why aren't other people
making their papers available?
So these inclusivity
aspects, I think,
are easy to under appreciate.
When you have
resources already, you
don't realize what
the barriers are
to getting access to things.
I mean, first of all, I
just wanted to second that.
So I work in Mexico,
and I'm fairly
fortunate to work at
[INAUDIBLE], which
has pretty good resources
and fairly good access
to literature.
But I did previously
work in an institution
that had almost no
access to the literature,
and saw what that
did on a daily basis
to our ability to
teach students,
our ability to do research.
And so when you do see
that on a daily basis,
it really hits home,
the importance of what
we're talking about here.
And with respect to
open data specifically,
you hear a lot of concerns.
In Mexico we have limited
finances for research.
So every little piece of data
that I can get is so crucial,
and I have to suck all
the juice out of that.
So why would I share
it with somebody?
On the other hand,
if other researchers
are sharing their
data, I might be
able to get access to data
sets that I couldn't possibly
collect where I
am because there's
no way I'm going
to have the funds
for that type of equipment.
So neural recording.
I'm not going to have
fancy neural recording.
I'm trying to scrape together
a patch clamp break right now,
and we're pulling
things out of closets.
And that's the kind of level
that we're at right now.
So there's that flip side to it.
I could get a very significant
benefit from people
outside opening up
their data, but there
has to be some kind of
reciprocation. that's
the problem.
I'm kind of stalling here
because your second question is
really not an easy
one to answer, which
is why I was bringing it
up as a potential concern
going forward, this
filtering issue.
How do you decide
what's important
and what's not important, and
how do you kind of put weights
to that?
So a lot of people--
previously-- well,
number of citations.
Well, that's a
fairly poor metric.
Journal impact
factor even worse,
because it's a
journal level metric,
it doesn't say anything about
the actual individual piece
of work.
And so there have been a lot
of efforts around alt metrics,
so can you kind of get a bigger
picture of how much impact
a piece of work is having?
So Tweets and Facebook
and news media coverage
and things like that.
And try to get quantitative
and qualitative idea
of how big an impact
a piece of work
is having, and then have some
type of ranking based on that.
And a lot of people get very
concerned that, well, you
can game these metrics.
Well, you can game
citation counts, too.
And citation counts,
to a certain extent,
are also popularity contests.
So labs get popular,
those names get big,
and you cite that
one just because it
has the big name
versus somebody who
might have made a similar
discovery around the same time.
So I think there's
not an easy answer.
But there's a lot of
people, like Impact Story,
who are working on how
we might get a broader
picture of an impact of a
piece of work, and then work on
and ranking and filtering.
We had somebody who
presented earlier
on this idea of up
voting or down voting,
and then commenters can sort
of build their reputation
over time, a Reddit-type
system that I
think is also interesting.
So I don't think
we have a solution,
but I there are a lot of
very smart people working
on these problems.
So I hope they will have
a better answer for you
than I do in couple
of years from now.
I'm kind of like Brian was on
that other issue, which is, I
think it's going to get solved.
Look, I think all
the consumer sites
are kind of working
on this, figuring
how do you manage the gaming?
And I think what
we have to realize
is we have to get away from
an omnibus kind of score.
But it's like, who
is it influencing?
Where is it good for?
Even for you, you're
interested in the curation.
You may want to be
interested in scores
from certain kinds of people or
certain ways it's being done.
I see this as moving fast.
People are going to come up
with a lot of different ways.
You'll have, I think,
a lot of options.
The question will be the demand.
So as this starts
spreading and we
start being inundated by
the amount of possibilities,
there's going to demand
to try to come up
with ways to customize
what you want,
and also for you to understand
who's making use of it
and how it's going.
I think it could become
more democratic in a way
because you're right.
And there's plenty
of studies showing
this whole thing about
citation is totally flawed.
I mean, certain things
get hot, and they
actually-- in my field
people aren't even
reading the literature anymore.
So there are papers
that either we publish,
other people publish that
we think are important,
and they're totally
ignored in the papers.
They're just sort of
like doing a quick look.
Maybe they're looking at the
last paper that was published
and pulling out some stuff
from their reference section
and just moving forward.
And I'm seeing, actually,
less thorough understanding
of what the literature is, a
great need to improve that.
And I know adding more is not
going to be the solution to it.
But I think the status
quo is a big problem.
And so the popularity
contest here
isn't necessarily merit-based.
It's sort of
name-based, and so we're
going to have to figure
out what it is that it's
going to move us forward.
Yeah.
We are overwhelmed
with information
in every part of our lives.
And there's a lot of
commercial organizations
whose business model depends
on good filtering of that
for their success.
When I go to New York, I use
Yelp, and most of the time
the restaurant I
go to is like, oh,
yeah, that was a good choice.
So then I continue to use Yelp.
What you really want to know is
how much the person liked it.
Like you, I mean, I feel
like that on Flixster
and all those things.
I mean, they they need to get
better too, because Rotten
Tomatoes, I don't care what
the average Rotten Tomatoes
score is.
I want to know people who
like the movies that I like.
They haven't begun to customize
that yet, but they will.
And in five years no one
is ever going to see,
well, this is the average
Rotten Tomatoes score.
It's really popular
because all the people
that rated it like
that kind of movie.
They all went to it
and they all rated it.
And I think in our field
it will be the same thing.
And I think what we'll
have to be careful about
is not getting in a bubble where
all of a sudden our interests--
and they just feed us stuff.
So we have to be
able to say, we also
want the random one coming our
way that somehow tickles you.
So all this stuff, though,
I think will get worked out.
So I think something else
we have to be vigilant about
is who controls these tools, who
controls this infrastructure.
I think we should.
Well, right.
Right.
The two of us.
Oh, no, no.
But you mentioned
commercial entities.
So there are
publishers right now
that are trying to
latch onto the idea
that open is becoming
popular and use
that to gain financially.
There was a particular
publisher that
was getting into the
metrics game in terms
of research or evaluation.
And the problem is that
because these are closed tools
and closed systems, for
example, we don't know,
is that publisher weighting
their journals heavier
than other people's journals?
We don't know because we
can't see inside that.
Thomson Reuters has
been controlling
impact factor for years.
We should boycott all of that.
Yeah, we should, and there
are lots of people who have.
I mean, there's
the San Francisco--
A place like Yale would
take the lead on that.
So this would be fantastic.
So how many people have heard
of the San Francisco Declaration
on Research Assessment, SF DORA?
So this is a statement that
says we are essentially
boycotting impact factor.
We're not going to use it in
any hiring, promotion, tenure,
evaluation.
And it's got over 12,000
individual signatories
and I think 900 organizations.
But if places like Yale
then sign this and then
act on it, because it's not
just going and signing it.
It's signing it and
then saying we're
going to remove the
mention of impact factor
in all of our tenure and
promotion guidelines.
We're going to explicitly
say that committees are not
supposed to look at this
when evaluating candidates
for new positions,
that type of thing.
So yes, we should boycott
these things as individuals,
as institutions, and
be very vigilant who's
controlling this
infrastructure, and are
we able to see inside it
and see what's going on?
So I think that's why it's so
important that, for example,
you guys are building tools that
are open source and people can
see what's under the hood, and
people can grab it and modify.
What should we do with Facebook?
I'm not going there.
You guys can touch that one.
Brian and I were talking
about this, though.
I totally agree
with you about that.
I was just raising this
other issue, though,
about these fake news
groups and all this.
This is where I think how
this stuff gets-- there
will be need for some curation.
And so how that gets
done, who does it,
and the degree of transparency
around how it's done.
All of these are going to be
important facets, I think.
I'll just say I think that could
be a role for the university
because it knows
its researchers,
it knows the domains,
and that they
could be a gatekeeper in that
way, as well as a leader.
That's another good role
for the institution.
Karen, do we have
time for one more?
Yeah.
You have the final word.
Well, this is really
just a follow-up
of the curation question.
Just do you think
artificial intelligence has
any role in that
in terms of, kind
of like, equivalent to
decision support or Watson
trying to make judgments about
what's valid and not valid?
Yeah.
And how far it can go.
Who knows?
If it can start writing my
papers for me, all the better.
But there are lots of
interesting advances
that are looking
for relationships
that are hard to detect.
The Allen Institute has
some interesting new tools
along those lines about
the scientific literature.
So yeah, I think there's
lots of potential there.
Yeah, so we were just discussing
text and data mining yesterday
at the poster session, and kind
of how quickly those tools are
advancing.
So the Content Mine, for
example, is one project.
So their goal is to
extract a million facts
from the literature.
Well, I can't do that by hand.
But the amazing text
and data mining tools
that they're developing can.
And also I was looking
into a project with them
on an image mining.
So we have all these neural
traces in the literature.
And right now, if I want to
get an idea of the diversity
of that, I have to go
one paper at a time
and look at those figures.
And it's just a ridiculous
task to do manually,
especially if now
I have to consider
all the pre-print literature and
all the published literature,
and maybe open datasets as well.
But as we're developing new
text and data mining tools--
not me, them-- you can
extract this information.
So they had this
really nice kind
of proof of concept
demonstration
where they were able
to pull out the data,
recreate the data from a
figure, and put it back
into a spreadsheet that now you
could analyze and play with.
And so the potential
for that, I think,
would be incredible if we
could do large scale analyses
and comparisons
across neural traces,
or across other types
of chemical structures,
or things like that
we can't do manually.
I'd just say I don't
think there's any choice.
It's going to be that way.
But there'll be
performance enhancers.
I don't think they'll replace.
There'll be guides, different
tools people can use.
I'm not an AI expert myself.
But what I've read is
there's some concern even
among those experts about
the black box effect,
because algorithms
have gotten so
complex and sophisticated
that it becomes
difficult to go back and
validate what comes out,
the output of this at times.
OK?
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
So in addition to
thanking the keynotes,
I actually wanted to
give a round of applause
for all the speakers
we had today.
It was just some
fantastic talks.